hello and welcome to this video playing
doom ICC yo well Demasi see what are you
going to play nothing ok now he's going
for move ok so we have the squash tell
ya I can't a coward resist playing this
somewhat incorrect line just like the
move Queen age for too much
yeah III is the move now now g-form
tweenage 4 and so on yeah this is
something that was him yeah analyzed by
Kasparov back I think it 2001 when Peter
Leko tried to slide with black against
him and he gave them he assessed this is
not better for white modern engines
don't agree and yeah I'm absolutely not
sure I mean it still would trust Trust
trust spar of a lot with his judgment
but I think it's really not easy to
evaluate looks a bit strange though for
black here but I tried to be a quicker
and not not to spend too much time I
mean I'm playing so badly at the moment
um I probably but it doesn't matter it
was spent a couple of seconds or have a
minute on a more okay if I have got 95
so that doesn't really threaten much
I have ideas like see for a three
against the skin okay Queen f3 so see
for Bishop chicks hmm I cantique see for
tix my cheeks moon I Scott bishop t5 it
doesn't work at all I mean maybe I can
take with the rook but maybe
rookie for Bishop g5 55 I can take on f4
kids just going back okay I can't play
Queen f4 for porn ok check
so that looks okay right I've won this
pawn okay so if you place if he doubles
I just have to six another big issue
so how'd you how to convert like to
enter with the rook sound the
second-ranked and maybe do something
with the night
Jess wanted to do that anyway okay if I
go look b8 he in I'm attacking b2c I
came to ship c2s culture still cut that
and Knight to f4 is probably quite good
this bishop doesn't have a stable square
Bishop c4 i have d 5 and then he will
have to allow me to go to e2 or
potentially check on d3 yeah i was
thinking c 6 cm yeah if it takes that i
have 93 check and rotary tools must be
decisive check King the one look II to
each was made next move root T 2 and T I
can check one it's gotta be 55 at the
end system
Master should play it why don't I take
first is what I wanted to do originally
okay it's probably not a big difference
the play look B 2 and then we'll get you
check yeah probably not a huge
difference so the bishop I need to get
it away from age who may be here I can
take on f4 still not too late to blunder
this pollution remarkable so how to do
this night on c2 would be cute if I go
look see to hear to take C 3 maybe this
Group C for I have 95 threatening I'd be
three okay he's not threatening anything
I don't care I'm everything I have
discovered but i don't so I still don't
see a clear win I to see two would be
good but and get down okay let's speed
up a little bit
can you take it because of made chai
morning I'm blundering f7 damn it it's
unbelievable it gets really really
remarkable I just can't be too after
that okay I'm probably winning on time
like 5x one-time power pretty struggling
here with the simplest things okay so
yeah this is a set a pretty em um yeah a
pretty on controversial opening position
normally I think they play Knight f3 in
this position but ok what he did cannot
be bad and yeah White has a huge space
advantage but okay I have some play
against the forint doubles here are
quite stable pieces at the moment ya
hear okay this is some probably
debatable so we should be five why can
you play that I mean that's some on the
move but I thought I can just do this
I'm losing you to this ok this would
have been a nice way to lose again
blundering the route he had chick made
so I was losing again in this position
Bishop t5 you know I didn't calculate
for enough he went back and now i'm
having this pawn and probably a winning
position check ok this was very helpful
check and yeah it simply couldn't finish
the game
check probably i'm keeping a huge
advantage but i'm still kind of
struggling yeah blonde i have seven here
with the deform which is amazing check
yeah and this position isn't even that
clear yeah okay i have to fight my way
out of that then slump okay thanks for
watching